and more and more and more as you come
up in a regular guy like this
with a 4.6 GPA you know 15 10 s 18.
you know all of a sudden you're like uh
man you can actually win here and then
gradually the levels to winning keeps
going you're like you know what else is
possible here it's just like playing a
game I'm gonna play this game out and
see where it goes and then obviously
I can sell this is the greatest country
in the world comfortably
in many different ways results Freedom
you know what we've been able to produce
why so many people come here if we're a
restaurant it's a restaurant that's
always full everybody's in line trying
to get into this restaurant even when
we're busy even more people want to come
here legally illegally risk their lives
it doesn't matter everybody wants to
come your